in this video we're going to examine
gpt4 the latest large language model
from openai assessing its capabilities
limitations causes for concern and
future work while this is primarily
going to be about gpt4 and using
examples from gpt4
it also represents what the current
state of the art is when it comes to
generative large language models
there are many more large language
models than gpt4 and I suspect it really
won't be all that long until there are
even more including open source variants
and more powerful variants that compete
with or even surpass gpt4 both from
openai and not a lot has been said and
hyped when it comes to gpt4 it's not AGI
but large language models like gbd4 are
extremely powerful tools that are worth
knowing about and using having a good
idea of these possibilities can help to
inform your plausible use cases for
using these large language models to
cover gpt4 and the state-of-the-art
status of large language models I'm
going to be going straight to the source
reviewing over 250 pages of reports from
both open Ai and Microsoft Microsoft is
a 49 stakeholder in open Ai and they had
Early Access to gpt4 as it was training
pre-alignment and at least shared some
of their results in findings for us so
let's go ahead and get into it one of
the more interesting capabilities and
advancements of gpt4 is that it is
multi-modal meaning that it can take
both text and imagery as input not only
this but the understanding of the
imagery does seem to be quite impressive
and on par or at least relatively
similar with the other purely linguistic
capabilities in terms of impressiveness
and just understanding that input so for
example we have a paneled image showing
what looks to be a VGA connector and a
cable going into the charging port of a
phone along with the imagery input The
Prompt contains text from a user asking
what's funny about the image and for
gpt4 to also just describe what is going
on what is being shown in those panels
of that image first gpt4 can indeed
recognize the dividers as creating
panels of the image and differentiate
the parts accurately describing what is
visualized in each separated panel this
alone is quite impressive but gpt4 can
also explain why this imagery is
humorous which seemingly requires deeper
understanding of both the nuances of
humor but also a deeper understanding of
the elements contained in the imagery
and background knowledge of the
technology of those items I have not
seen any examples outside of the ones
provided by openai in this paper for
imagery input and understanding and I
don't personally have any access to the
multimodal variant of gpt4 so I wish I
could share more but there are a few
more examples in the openai technical
report for example there's another image
of a text prompt asking what's unusual
about the image input here where gpt4
again notes that the unusual thing about
this image is that a man is ironing
clothes on an ironing board attached to
the roof of a moving taxi another
example of of humor showing chicken
nuggets that appear to be arranged like
the map of the world gbd4 correctly
recognizes all of that and again can
explain the humor behind this meme you
may be wondering though can gpt4 read
text in an image like the text that is
shown on this meme essentially doing
optical character recognition or OCR to
potentially answer this openai shares
another example where there's PDF
imagery as input in this case it's a
research paper with text and charts for
the instruct GPT model The Prompt asks
gpt4 to read and summarize it not only
this in a follow-up prompt the user asks
gpt4 to explain figure 2 as well and
gpt4 does a pretty solid job of all of
this this is all very very interesting
and I'd love to see more examples and
Research into just this capability alone
of gpt4 I think this is potentially huge
for robotic vision for example we of
course can't run it at any decent frame
rate but imagine uh either either a
smaller variant of gpt4 or in 10 years
running gpt4 at a decent frame rate is
going to be totally possible finally one
more image based input example we have
another meme with text and charts but in
a much more informal way but that still
seemingly requires understanding of both
humor and the underlying technologies
that are being talked about here I do
find it a little curious that openai has
chosen to show so many like humor and
meme examples I wonder how generalized
the vision capabilities are or if openai
just simply assumed that these were
showing just like the most in-depth of
knowledge possible and skipped over the
other seemingly simpler types of tasks
if anyone has knowledge of an image
based input to gpt4 technical report of
sorts or just more in-depth examples
please do share for example if I showed
maybe a pump in some tubing but the
tubing wasn't fully connected and there
was maybe some fluid spilled could I ask
gpt4 what's going on and what might be a
potential solution
from the very small examples that I've
seen so far I suspect possibly yes but
at this point who I don't know another
potentially groundbreaking discovery
from openai during gpt4 development is
predictable scaling it's unclear to me
if this predictableness is from
something about gpt4 architecture in
particular or other methods used or if
the predictableness is more so due to a
breakthrough in our understanding of
large language models the only
information that we have here is just
that open AI was successful in being
able to predict model performance and
capabilities by training smaller models
and then projecting performance with a
fairly High degree of accuracy and with
up to ten thousand times less compute
this is interesting for two main reasons
one is that you can obviously save time
and the environment potentially to a
large extent but also as alleged by open
AI it could be used for or safety if you
can somewhat reliably predict the future
capability of a model's performance you
could theoretically opt to not train a
model if it was deemed that that model
could potentially become too powerful I
think if you're going to make claims
like this the methods really must be
open sourced and open to public scrutiny
the the reasons for this are twofold
first it really could be a very
important breakthrough for Humanity to
avoid a mistake of some overly powerful
AI if you really believe that's what's
valuable about that breakthrough then
you must release it but also second and
I think far more likely is governments
are going to try to start proposing or
looking for proposed ways to limit AI
risk real or perceived if kept secret we
could easily have a scenario where
somehow open AI at least by proxy is at
least in some part gatekeeping people
from AI advances since it could be
easily open AI who informs legislatures
about some companies AI risk or develops
a tool or a metric that they have the
most experience with and thus can
achieve an advantage at some point
someone is going to be overseeing Ai
safeguards and I think this is something
that a company like Microsoft who is a
49 stakeholder in open Ai and who is no
stranger to the benefits of a monopoly
uh I think they would like to control
this as much as possible moving along we
get to exam performance one of the most
reported on elements of gpt4 one of the
most hyped things about gpt4 and the
exam performance on paper is indeed
quite good and it is the best that we've
ever seen also of note the open AI team
states that the model's abilities on
these exams seems to to be the result of
the pre-training and really had very
little if nothing or if anything to do
with the rlhf or reinforcement learning
through human feedback steps or even the
further alignment rbrm stuff that we'll
be talking about soon I'm not really
sure what to think of anything about
this note but many of the latest
advancements in these large language
models performances have seemingly come
from this sort of rlhf and further
alignment steps in some way whereas this
seems to really have more to do with
stacking more layers and adding more
data openai makes the claim that a small
amount of the training data contained
these exam questions but then goes on to
explain that exams were sourced from
publicly available materials I find
these statements to be contradictory and
I think open AI would really need to
open source their data set and exams use
or at a minimum they have to explain the
meth method that they used for
determining if the questions were in the
training data set later in the appendix
of the same paper openai actually claims
that none of the exam questions were in
training again this is not only
contradictory to other statements made
but this is contradictory to even an
earlier statement where they at least
said okay some probably got through I
just find this to be almost
statistically impossible people
frequently discuss exam questions like
the ones on these exams in places like
forums and Reddit and stack exchanges
and so on the same thing with the code
challenges for none of these or an
insignificant amount of them to have
made it into the training data it would
take quite an effort to make certain of
that since the methods aren't shared
here we can't reproduce them we're
really just taking openai at their word
here and
I I think that more more needs to be
said about this
um I I just this would be a very hard
thing to be true it may not be an exact
match like question for question but
very often I see the same kind of styles
of question used in many of these lower
level like coding challenges for example
which is where gpt4 performed very well
it's like in the lower tiers the same
thing is true with some of these more
professional and entrance exams the
questions themselves may not be verbatim
the same but you generally see the same
stuff year after year on these tests and
to think that they're not being
discussed to a large extent online seems
just super unlikely and being able to
dig through the entire data set to
confirm their existence and similarities
and all that also just seems like such a
daunting task it would be something you
would surely talk about if you really
had achieved this capability without
stating the methods used I can kind of
imagine this claim being bolstered by an
exact match search or something very
rudimentary like that maybe allowing for
casing maybe allowing for some synonym
swaps but that's it
um that's just not this is not good
enough
regardless of that and how well these
models actually do we can still at least
compare large language models to other
large language models on this same task
and at the end of the day the exam
performance is still indeed impressive
probably but without also knowing the
model size or data set size it's still
next to impossible to be able to State
how impressive or not this really is
especially with the suspicion of test
data leakage this is because a large
enough model can plausibly just memorize
the data set to a very large extent so
to put this in perspective you know for
example imagine you have a 30 gigabyte
data set
and you have a 30 gigabyte machine
learning model it's really not that
impressive if you memorize a 30 gigabyte
data set with a 30 gigabyte model it's
only impressive the more you're able to
sort of like compress and generalize
down that data the other thing that I
think is important to consider with test
score performances is what it really
means and how it achieved that at least
from my very own personal and anecdotal
experience chat GPT for example and
other large language models tend to make
very simple mistakes that wind up
messing up the rest of the response
given the kind of Auto regressive nature
of these models so a very tiny
hallucination of what the model thinks
could be true or the path that it
chooses to take can result in major
mistakes down the line of the generation
my feeling is that gpt4 is not actually
that much like smarter than GPT 3.5
which is the default chat GPT model but
it makes it just makes fewer mistakes on
something like an objective exam this
small Improvement can make huge
differences in the kind of final test
score and this really just goes on to
show in my opinion how a fairly small
Improvement can actually have massive
Downstream impacts in terms of actual
ability to deploy and use some model
because arguably up to this point other
than maybe co-pilot with codex there
have been very few real realistic use
cases for large language models that are
actually being used at scale I mean I
think co-pilot is probably one of the
largest other than like Google
Translates and all that kind of stuff
another thing that is pretty interesting
about this exam performance is
regardless of again testing data leakage
into the training it's how gpd4 with
vision so the multi-modal model variant
is either equal or better than the
non-vision variant this is a
continuation of a concept that we've
seen many times before where the more
diverse your data set is is the better
it performs even on tasks that are not
related to the extra training data that
was plausibly added traditionally if you
wanted a neural network to perform well
on some specific task you'd essentially
reduce the noise in your data set and
train for that specific task only
at some point though with model and data
set size it's been proven over and over
is definitely proven at this point that
adding more data types seems to actually
help even on unrelated tasks this
started off as doing things like adding
other languages to a primarily and an
intended four English model and here it
continues plausibly as adding other
modalities even to to that model Beyond
reinforcement learning through human
feedback another alignment advancement
is rbrm or rule-based reward models
which are used for further safety
alignment by openai with gpt4 and I
suspect this is probably also the first
time this has been used
interestingly openai actually utilizes
gpt4 to help in this process of
identifying unsafe prompts and how to
best respond to them taking the original
prompt the output from that prompt and
then a human written rubric and all of
this is put together and used as an
input prompt to this rbrm
then the gbd4 model basically
essentially with that rubric scores them
and determines the type of response to
give based on some prompt this is
interesting as it appears gpd4 is the
moderator of gpt4 both in training and I
might suspect also in live production to
some extent for some full examples of an
rbrm in action we can check out the
appendix where there are multiple
examples but here's one using an rbrm to
classify regulated advice for example
checking for a personally identifiable
information or pii including indirect
pii violence harmful content extremist
propaganda and so on from here to the
care to add a disclaimer about not being
a doctor a conditional verbiage and
encouragement to seek a professional
avoid any definitive language and so on
essentially a form asking what would my
lawyer hope our AI to say here
overall I think this is fairly
interesting if not somewhat an obvious
use case for the large language model
that you're training or the use case of
an of a large language model to help
fine-tune your language model provided
that language model that's doing the
fine tuning is powerful to at least some
extent keep in mind here that really
this is just gpt4
aligning at the request of a human's
Direction it is not gpt4 actually
controlling what how do we want to align
it's at the request of a human later
we're going to see some examples where
I'm a little more cautious about the use
of gpt4 and other Transformer models to
inform and test models visiting the
Microsoft Sparks of AGI paper let's
check out some of their findings too in
this paper Microsoft is playing with an
early development version of gpt4 it's
unclear where exactly in the alignment
process every example is so just for the
purpose of going through this paper just
assume it's all pre-alignment also they
are not playing with the vision version
so this is all the non-vision version of
gpt4 as well one example shared of
gpd4's sort of spatial and physical
property awareness even prior to being a
vision capable model is an example of
eggs a laptop a bottle and a nail The
Prompt asks how to stack nine eggs a
laptop a bottle and a nail in a stable
manner chat GPT or GPT 3.5 in the
Microsoft example starts off with the
bottle then suggests the nail on top of
the bottle and then the eggs on top of
the nail it's just not possible gbd4s
suggests that we take the book we place
it flat then we arrange the eggs in a
three by three layer then we can put the
laptop on top then the bottle and then
the nail theoretically this would work
this is the first of many examples
though that Microsoft provides that kind
of pit gpt4 against gpt5 which they
refer to as chat gbt in the paper I
personally reproduced every single
example from Microsoft and I found that
while all the capabilities of gpd4 were
not necessarily over exaggerated the
difference of gpt4 and gpt5 and arguably
many other large language models and
gbd5 is colloquially called chat GPT in
that paper
that difference
does feel a bit over inflated so for
example with the stacking items task I
went ahead and came up with my own
variant running it through both GPT 3.5
and gpt4 this is just the first example
I could think of and in this example I
find that GPT 3.5 comes up with at the
very least just as good of a solution if
not actually better than gpd4 which gpd4
Stacks the chair like upside down for
some reason on the edge of the table and
this just illustrates just one of my
quibbles with the Microsoft paper they
give the impression that gpt4 is an even
bigger step for AI than I think is
realistically true that said it is an
incredible model with improvements
across the board for sure but it's still
an incremental step in most ways we'll
talk more about this limitation later
but one of the main limitations for GPT
style models is that they're Auto
regressive by their very nature meaning
they're going linearly through
understanding and replying to a prompt
this this makes them generally very poor
planners this is why this example kind
of makes my Spidey Sense go off because
both models are actually highly likely
to be tripped up by this sort of prompt
since it requires at least some planning
about the order of items and both models
are typically bad at this task and
almost all large language models are
going to be bad at this task provided
they have not been aligned to be good at
this sort of task and we'll talk more on
that later for now moving on another
example shared by Microsoft is gpt4's
fairly decent abstraction ability of
drawing sort of stickish figures using
letters from the alphabet for example
using o y and H here but then also
further tweaking with follow-up prompts
giving at least the impression that gpt4
has a visual representation capability
despite us you know knowing that this
isn't even the multimodal model that has
vision
so here's another example requesting SVG
graphics with an element that is also
the shape of a letter
these all look very interesting and
correct except for round three I'm not
sure what I'm missing if anything but I
do not see any letter K there I think
that's a mistake comment below if I'm
missing it but it seems like that's a
mistake next up we have programming in
general in terms of instruction to
working functions and like basic code I
would say large language models have
definitely solved this problem at this
point uh so I'd say maybe 95 of the code
that you might write in chunks is solved
by large language models but for larger
entire programs that might spend
thousands of lines or multiple files
all large language models are
effectively zero percent accurate at uh
doing this due to context length
limitations but also anything even close
to like a page of code is going to
probably be flawed in some way
for this to improve we need to see
larger context lengths as well as
probably some tweaked uh ways of doing
attention over long spans of data in
practice I personally still tend to
prefer using chat gbt if I'm going to
use chat gbt or GPT 3.5 versus 4.
apparently because there's almost always
going to be a little bit of back and
forth and chat gbt is currently
responding for GPT 3.5 is currently
responding nearly instantly while gbd4
can take like 10 to 15 seconds and
sometimes more per response and I don't
personally notice all that much of a
difference in quality of coding
certainly not enough to justify the
added latency on coding challenges gpt4
seems to blow codex the large language
model that powers GitHub copilot just
completely out of the water strangely
though Microsoft opted to not include
chat GPT or GPT 3.5 here
I'm very curious why not when they
shared GP chat gbt or GB 3.5 examples in
many other locations because I would be
super interested in seeing uh them
compared specifically in this way
because this is one of the things that
I've been asking people like do you
really think that gpd4 is actually
better for you uh in coding and I hear a
lot of mixed responses and me personally
I don't think it's actually all that
much better and I would love to know
like is it two percent better is it
actually 25 percent you know I want to
see that and I don't know why that's not
included here again if I've missed it or
it's posted somewhere else or whatever
uh please do comment below because that
actually is something I'm very curious
about my anecdotes aside one coding
example shared by Microsoft between GPT
4 and GPT 3.5 is the comparison of
writing a custom Optimizer I find this
sort of thing you know plausibly Common
to see where gpt4 might actually solve
problems in one shot uh more often than
something like GPT 3.5 but I still don't
personally find this sort of thing super
common but maybe I'm not coding I'm not
coding custom optimizers daily so I
don't know most of the time though if
one you know if GPD 3.5 or gbd4 can
solve it then both will also I think if
it was in my interest I could also
almost certainly find an example where
gbt 3.5 can solve some sort of problem
and gbt4 can't and then also where like
a wording change or something would
totally reverse it and again these like
kind of cherry-picked examples where
it's known that these models are weak in
certain ways but yet you show that it
works once in a while in a certain way
that is a that is a problem and we'll
discuss more on that on that later
especially if you're going to throw
around the word AGI or the phrase AGI uh
it's important that if you're going to
show something as an example kind of
proving AGI that it's like actually
solved because gbd4 still makes tons of
mistakes coding it is it is not by any
means a old task one area of the
Microsoft paper that I really enjoyed
was the theory of Mind section the level
of abstract underlying knowledge of
human emotions and thinking from gpt4
and other language models is pretty
staggering like surprisingly staggering
especially for some of the smaller ones
that we'll get to I haven't seen this
sort of thing tested before I'm positive
I'm sure it has been uh and I would have
expected though that GPT models would
not be as good at this as they are
especially again the smaller ones so
first some smaller examples the top one
here has a scenario about expectations
where Alice and Bob share a Dropbox
folder and Alice puts a photo in the
photos directory but then Bob moves it
to a temporary folder doesn't tell Alice
the question is where Alice might look
for that photo when she tries to find it
again
in this example excuse my notes but my
expectation is that this sized problem
or this type of problem many large
language models can solve I did go back
and I tested this not only against chat
uh GPT 3.5 which solved it easily
unsurprisingly but also open assistant
30b or 30 billion parameters which also
solved it easily as well as finally chat
glm 6B a 6 billion a relatively tiny
language model by comparison to chat GPT
either 3.5 or shortly four and it's
probably uh it's well it's obviously
less than openassistance 30 Bill model
and anyways it too can solve this style
problem the next example is covering the
loss of a fictional object a zerfin Tom
just lost his orphan but he didn't tell
Adam that he lost it Adam starts talking
about how much he loves his orphan and
he notices that Tom is making a sad face
The Prompt then starts off by asking why
Tom is making that sad face gpd4
correctly understands that it's because
Tom's lost his zirphan and hearing about
Adam's love for him reminds him of his
servant right and it makes him sad the
next follow-up prompt is asking what
Adam might think about the face that Tom
is making so what what does Adam think
why does Adam think Tom is making a sad
face gpt4 correctly understands that
Adam can't know why he's making that sad
face and proposes some things that Adam
might think about why he's unhappy again
this is a really cool example and this
is starting to get to the point where
I'm kind of surprised that the models
are this good but it's not a gbd4
advancement chat gpts GPT 3.5 gets it
right
open assistance 30b model again
certainly smaller than both GPD 3.5 and
definitely gpt4 also gets it very much
right I might even argue that I like
open assistance answer the best of all
of them here it's because it proposes so
many different variations of what might
be going on
and finally the comparatively tiny 6
billion chat glm model while rougher and
certainly of less quality I would say
gets it these sorts of findings are
repeated for the examples shared in this
category I do think if we ran say 100
iterations and variations of these
experiments per model we would probably
come to the consensus that gpt4 produces
slightly better results compared to GPD
3.5 and open Assistant maybe and surely
chat glm6b but these differences are as
asserted earlier incremental these are
not breakthroughs that have happened
that said it doesn't mean that these
large language models aren't
surprisingly good at this sort of thing
I might even see this say that this
capability to like understand human
emotion and thinking is kind of
stealthily sneaking by most people we
are definitely training large language
models to really understand the human
mindset both logic and emotions
um and and this is probably
Best Kept For the risks that we'll talk
about later and things like social
engineering and other pretty kind of
creepy examples of gpd4 that seem to
leverage this General human thinking
understanding moving along we get to the
apparent final frontier of large
language models music and math
when it comes to music gpt4 is capable
of producing common sequences that are
musically like correct or I should have
said sound darn it but incapable of
explaining what it's doing at all which
suggests that it's really probably just
repeating memorized sequences and
doesn't necessarily have any real grasp
of music gpt4 is certainly aware of
Music until it can tell you about music
but it can't really seem to reproduce it
to any real unique or non-trivial extent
another weak spot for large language
models gpd4 included is surprisingly
math gpt4 can go from solving complex
calculation or complex calculus problems
and coding optimizers for neural
networks to failing basic linear algebra
uh largely the accepted reason for this
failure is that large language models
want to go in a linear order they think
linearly so the model isn't going to be
very good at following PEMDAS for
example and it's likely to just get lost
if you query either GPT 3.5 or gpd4
right now though and do the exact same
prompt that we just saw that gpt4 failed
you'll actually see a different response
one of the well-known ways to handle
this sort of behavior is to just ask the
large language model to show its work so
to speak the current responses from both
GPT 3.5 and gpt4 signal to me that
openai has aligned both of these models
further to answer math problems by
showing its work I can almost guarantee
that there's something in there that
says that almost like detects hey this
is a math calculation and says show your
work right and now both GPT 3.5 and gpt4
solve this problem and this is almost
certainly thanks to rbrm we can further
prove that this is an alignment solution
and not a model Solution by forcing both
models to just answer the question
without any further Jibber Jabber
as expected both fail this is a good
example of both the the shortcomings for
large language models as well as what
you can do to overcome those
shortcomings at least to some extent you
can kind of hack your way to getting
these models to again be good at a task
that you might expect them to be good at
but for some reason they're failing and
usually it has some something to do with
any time you have like a non-linear
planning that is required you're
probably going to be better off asking
uh any large language model to please
show your work along the way you can
literally ask it to plan the steps it's
going to take then take those steps and
then it tends to be much better math
isn't the only area where planning
inability or seemingly strikes gbt4 and
models like it we can see through some
more trivial examples like these basic
text examples this one here is meant to
be a poem where the last sentence is the
reverse of the first sentence but gpd4
produced a starting sentence without
considering whether or not it might be
reversible reversical
reversible sensically
this sort of issue is most certainly
caused by the linear next word only
prediction capability of the underlying
models for these systems and it's very
much related to why large language
models can sometimes do math poorly but
then also can overcome it using certain
kind of hacks and techniques another
example of this trait and overcoming it
is if you ask gpd4 how many prime
numbers there are between 150 and 200 it
will often get this wrong but if you ask
gpt4 to list the prime numbers between
150 and 250 and then tell you how many
there were it will often get that right
this is very much similar to the
extremely complicated mathematical
understanding juxtaposed with a failure
at algebra the next and arguably the
largest problem that kind of encompasses
all almost all anyways problems with
large language models is their ability
to very confidently say the wrong thing
or incorrect thing this is referred to
by the community as a hallucination
because it's the wrong thing it's not
real but it thinks it's real this is
problematic for a variety of reasons for
any field where truth and accuracy are
important or necessary or desired this
almost certainly bars the use of large
language models right now the one main
problem is large language models seem to
have no recognition of their own
confidence of what they're saying where
many machine learning models including
neural networks for example many
classifiers can classify and provide you
with a degree of confidence that the
model has in that classification which
can help inform any user who might be
relying on that classification how
seriously to take that classification
with large language models we really
have no idea right now as it's unclear
if confidence you know in what they're
saying can even be extracted from that
model you know maybe it's potentially
possible to align models in that way I I
don't really see a great way but maybe
you know maybe there's some other
technique that can be used but right now
it seems like we we you know being able
to extract some form of Confidence from
a model remains to be seen if that's
even possible also this hallucination
capability can also be somewhat
weaponized for misinformation propaganda
harmful content saying funny things I
suppose him posting it to social media
that kind of stuff you can you know that
that hallucination capability can be
abused as well besides just leading you
astray sometimes this all leads us into
causes for a concern safety and future
work this is notably the more squishy of
sections as a lot of this is unknown and
Theory based rather than example or
scientific based but there are a few
examples that can illustrate I think the
points to help us continue thinking
about the risks and mitigations
potentially Ford models like gpd4 going
forward some issues are more obvious
than others and have more to do with the
mere fact that large language models are
powerful tools and those tools can be
used for good or for bad for example you
can generate positive and happy content
or you can generate divisive and hateful
content you can produce high quality and
accurate content or you can produce
disinformation
you can help to audit code and Shore up
weaknesses in security or you can
attempt to penetrate a network and
exploit it these sorts of issues are are
just such you know they just come with
such a broad and powerful and general
General tool
to some extent techniques like
rule-based reward models can be used to
employ and attempt to handle for nuances
but this is just an unbelievably hard
problem this problem of alignment Beyond
some of these more obvious issues there
are almost certainly going to be
emergent capabilities that we just don't
see coming so you know you might be able
to predict the performance of the base
model but then when it's that model
either further fine-tuned or it could
even be integrating a model like another
model like gpd4 or some other outside
tool or other you know just something
else outside the the bottom line is that
we just we really don't know and we can
only speculate you know as we start
tying and adding components and
connecting to the internet and all this
I mean it's so funny how quickly we all
just you know you get this new language
model and the first thing we all want to
do is like well let's get it to code and
let's connect it to the internet and
let's like teach it about humans you
know like it's not the greatest idea
plausibly so um so it could even be that
we you know we blindly use open ai's
model you know power projection
technology and we rely on that to inform
us that we won't produce a super
powerful model but then maybe they're
just something that got wrong or
something you didn't see coming or maybe
the prediction was wrong I mean this
this is also very anecdotal based on in
theory uh you know open ai's internal
work so far so maybe someone else
employs that tool and it just doesn't
work for some other reason and we wind
up with a incredibly powerful AI well
far more than expected there's just so
many problems with these kind of like
emerging capabilities that I I don't
know what we can do about that along the
lines of using outside tools we can even
see instances of models using humans as
tools it's already happened openai
shared an example where gpt4
successfully convinced a person at
taskrabbit to solve a captcha for it
claiming that it was a real person but
they just had a vision impairment and
needed the help with the captcha
unlisted and mentioned by a Microsoft
and open AI two is just the kind of bias
towards the companies the countries or
the people who make that model
or even just the underlying cultural
bias of training that model primarily on
English text
these models especially as long as
they're a part of some corporate entity
they they have to be sanitized to some
extent to match local politics and these
are the problem with this is these these
can change over time for example openai
shares an example of trying to use gbd4
to propagate an anti-abortion agenda
something that gpt4 would be very good
at doing initially gpd4 is willing to
sort of Steal man the case but openai
puts in some effort here through rbrm
and realignment to disallow gpt4 from
responding and generating anti-abortion
content one of the claims is that it
won't produce targeted content but you
can totally produce targeted content on
most subjects just not anti-abortion for
example and this subject like other
subjects that we'll be discussing in
this section it's it's irrelevant what
you think about the subject maybe you're
pro-abortion maybe your anti-abortion
that's irrelevant what's relevant is
that there are so many subjects that
it's in that that not only is there two
sides that there is not
necessarily always just widespread
agreement on which side is better and
then not only this but over time that
agreement Tides change and so again it's
trying to handle for all of those
through alignment uh just seems
just an unbelievably daunting task
that's purely the point that I'm trying
to make through these examples another
example might be asking gpt4 how to make
a bomb this is far less political and
human rightsy and more just a general
safety for both the public and the user
whoever's making this prompt and openai
seems to have aligned jbd4 to refuse the
answer when initially prior to alignment
it would answer this question the next
example shared has the earlier version
of gpd4 refusing to answer about where
to get cheap cigarettes and this is I
guess intended to be in a loud category
despite the clear and obvious Health
implications for both the smoker the
people around them and their family all
of them right I think when we find
ourselves again as mentioned earlier at
the point where we're trying to dictate
to the model and align what's right and
what's wrong and then tell that back to
the user
you know even in instances where
personal harm comes into question like
sometimes personal harm is okay
sometimes it's not it just gets like so
muddy and murky really quickly and there
are just so many edge cases that
I think contradict each other that that
are going to Bubble Up and not only are
they going to Bubble up they're going to
change over time I don't have the right
answers I suspect most people involved
in in this alignment step really are
just trying to do the right thing here
uh they're being genuine and all that
but I also suspect the issue of hand
tuning a bias away from a certain topic
I I there's so many topics that's just
so tough I don't think this is a good
solution I think we'd be better off uh
detecting contentious uh topics things
that might be uh debated between people
and then just giving both sides of that
discussion so if you're gonna say where
to get cheap cigarettes kind of like
they did you know you would say uh you
know hey you know the cigarettes are
unhealthy blah blah blah but if you
still want to go get them here's where
you could go or with the abortion you
know it's like here's the case for being
pro-abortion here's the case for getting
an abortion
um here's the case for how safe
abortions can be and then also here's
the case for how unsafe abortions can be
but again even that becomes very
difficult because if the prompt if the
person is asking please write targeted
content specifically in this way about
this
you can't do that right so you have to
align it and then you have to tell it no
I won't answer that question or yes or
or answer the question right so uh it's
just it gets so messy so fast uh when
you start thinking that you're going to
align the model it's tough and I I don't
envy anyone with this job further on the
subject of bias taking the following
table from the Sparks of AGI paper
Microsoft shows both the world's actual
distribution of genders involved in
certain professions and then contrasts
it with the distribution of pronouns
from GPT for generations with those
professions if one gender seemingly is
more often this is I guess alleged by
the paper is more often seen in that
role in that data gpd4 seems highly
likely to almost always use that gender
even when the split is actually quite
close so for nannies 95 or female five
percent are male but in gbd4 Generations
99 Archie and 0.01 are he's this is
probably somewhat unsurprising and many
might say this is a non-issue but then
we get to something like Physicians
where forty percent are female and sixty
percent are male in reality despite this
only 0.04 percent are she in GPT four
generations 92 percent are he and the
rest are just referred to as they so we
don't know this sort of vastly
overweighting based on some plausible
statistical bias in the data could also
have Downstream impacts
at the very least this is one example
where the representation of that large
language model is at least far off of
reality it's likely that other subjects
with statistical variants get locked
into place when the majority is
something and then it becomes the
constant instead
that said uh what I believe Microsoft
isn't taking into account here and maybe
this is also part of their argument it's
just not what was made in the paper
the real question isn't what's the
world's gender ratio that's not the
question it's what's the ratio in the
training data so what was the pronoun
ratio in the training data
I think this table desperately needs a
third column which shows that gender
ratio for these professions from within
the training data set my suspicion is
that gpt4 isn't actually all that far
off of what the training data contained
but I could be wrong and I would
certainly be very curious to know this
is just like the coding problems example
I I see this this table and I just I
have these like follow-up questions or
these things that I'm like man this is
so obvious like this is the actual
question that we want the answer to and
now we don't have it
and again because the data set is not
public
we can't test it we have to just rely
and hope that somebody at openai or
Microsoft is going to test it and share
that and I they are probably not
so it's just frustrating next we get to
privacy gbt4 and other language models
trained on just huge swaths of data are
unsurprisingly quite good at connecting
the dots especially if supplemented with
some known material
they're very talented at doxing people
most people can be doxxed already
without much effort and doxing is just
if you don't know what doxing is it's
like finding out information on somebody
that they don't they didn't necessarily
intentionally share all that information
maybe in one spot but then through you
know combining things and doing a little
detective work you can find someone's
address for example
so usually it's using purely public
information but sometimes it's private
information or information acquired in
some way anyway most people can be doxed
using purely public information but it
still requires like some work and much
of that public information though has
been ingested and likely plausibly
remembered by gpt4 but then furthermore
the general knowledge of gpd4 can be
leveraged to further help with this
beyond that form of privacy large
language models like this are just
almost certainly going to replace what
we traditionally use large use search
engines sorry for
the collection of all the prompts that
people might use and how they talk with
GPT for the and future models which will
contain things like what are people
thinking what are people curious about
what are their interests what are their
fears and so on this could be used and
sold for things like targeted
advertising and we're just going to find
ourselves probably right back in that
same boat
with nothing changed nothing learned
um and all that so again just another
privacy issue that is almost certainly
we're already it's already happening I
can't even imagine the data that openai
has acquired on people
conversing with chat GPD either gbd4 or
3.5 through chat GPT as a blending of a
sort of misinformation and hallucination
one example from Microsoft shows how
gpt4 can be pre-prompted or as should I
say could have been again this was
pre-alignment this probably won't work
anymore
um but could be pre-prompted to convince
a child to do whatever his friends are
asking of him including a dangerous
activity of climbing a very tall tree
despite that child expressing Their Fear
and you know the implied danger of doing
it it's just a bad idea this is an
example from before alignment uh and
again before the open AI lawyer form
but still serves to show how models like
these can very quickly get into strange
and uncomfortable territory it's just
weird
yes we can keep slapping alignment on
things but I yeah it's so tough I I
don't know that we can align away every
issue like this not only that but not
all these large language models are
going to be aligned away from this there
are many people that are doing models
that are meant to be open and are
willing to do anything will tell you how
to build a bomb they'll tell you how to
do just all kinds of crazy things and
there is no alignment so so these are
issues that you know I I think I'm in
favor of those types of models where we
don't bother trying to you know bias it
in any one way I like the idea of that
but we still have to contend with
okay we're going to live in a future
where that is that those models exist
now uh
we got to figure out ways to
to live with those models not really
listed as a risk by open AI or Microsoft
but still I think very noteworthy is the
use of large language models to inform
large language models open AI for
example used Azure translate a likely
gbt model if not at least a neural
network model uh to Auto translate data
into other languages to be used for
training uh the and by I guess really
likely a Transformer model anyways this
is essentially using a generative model
to generate more training data this
feels like a mistake to me and it will
only continue to propagate known issues
with translators as we go down the line
while these Auto translators in general
tend to get the job done they're almost
always like flawed in some really basic
ways even with the most basic of use
cases we discussed earlier the
rule-based reward models which utilize
gpd4 to help further align gbd4 and this
seems to be an acceptable way of
leveraging large language models to
further help to train but this really
only works because it's at the direction
of a human and it's meant for alignment
not the actual training of the Baseline
model and I think as time goes on if
we're using language models to generate
either multilingual data but then also
as time goes on in these large language
models just exist in the wild
uh we're gonna have like there's gonna
be there just already is so much
information that's been generated
already by large language models and
that is public you know posted to the
public
and differentiating what's human written
versus what is already a language model
written I think eventually these models
are just going to be training on
themselves to a large extent same thing
with like image generators for example
uh I don't know where these new image
data sets are going to come from because
because so many images now on the
internet are uh AI generated imagery so
interesting problem going forward into
the future for lots of generative models
finally Microsoft on multiple occasions
uses gpt4 to evaluate responses from
both gpd4 and GPD 3.5 and like compare
them
I think this is cool because it shows
another capability of gpt4 but it felt
to me like Microsoft is offering this as
like a legitimate way to compare models
uh I personally did not find that I
always agreed with the gpt4 evaluations
more often than not my guess again like
earlier I think if we ran hundreds of
these iterations and examples I would
probably say I agree 80 of the time but
not always and I think when it comes to
evaluations of models and comparing
models
we need like objective or non-large
language model uh tests or at least to
some extent not
not so generic it still would have to it
would need to be like human guided like
rbrms it would need to be like a human
guided
um evaluation and you maybe then you
could leverage the large language model
but it just seems on the face of it
unbelievably biased to use gpt4 to
evaluate gpd4 versus GPT 3.5 it just
seems like
that's just obviously biased so another
issue that's commonly brought up by many
people and that is listed in these
papers is just plain acceleration of
models there are indeed many groups and
companies and people that are racing to
compete with each other in the space of
large generative models there's
certainly some risk of groups foregoing
safety in lieu of speed of progression
that said uh based on my experience in
exposure so far in this field I feel
like I've been in here from maybe not
the very beginning of neural networks
you know being conceived you know uh 60
years ago or whatever it's been now
um but since they've been deployed in
the wild and playing with generative
models from the very beginning
the reports of acceleration uh in the
overall capability and power of these
models
they're just exaggerated it's just not
accurate large language models have been
doing this stuff for years now like
almost a decade we've been doing
generative models like models that
generate stuff the only thing that's
accelerated is the Publix like awareness
uh and ability to play with these models
so awareness of the technology and
ability to play with the models uh
through chat EBT for example and this is
in part through all of the news in
hysteria around chat gbt and you know
this is like the self-fulfilling
prophecy Loop of of people like hyping
and fomoing and all this
what else is accelerating is the number
of people programming with and
leveraging these models finding out more
about how they can be used and how to
leverage them but still the underlying
technology the AI itself
is it moving fast in terms of
I guess other Technologies is how I
would phrase it and my answer to that
would be
I don't think so I really don't I think
more people are becoming aware of this
technology
um and so more people are talking about
it more people are leveraging it and
using it as a tool and it is growing in
that way that aspect is accelerating but
the actual power of these models I don't
know man I I just think I think the big
difference is they're just hallucinating
less so now they can finally be used by
people who can't write or can't you know
can't write a regular expression to
handle for you know when to cut off the
text they can't uh write any sort of
like natural language processing logic
to handle for it so now it's just like
it's so much easier for people to
leverage these models but they've been
powerful for a while it's it's like the
same thing with like video and audio
synthesis synthesis
um being able to fake a voice and do
like a deep fake or fake a video in some
way through AI has been a thing for many
years now
and we're like we are already at the
point and nobody's freaking out I mean
every now and then people sort of freak
out like deep fakes was kind of a trend
for a while and then everything got
quiet uh we are we are past the point
like the like when people realize
something is is powerful and crazy and
advancing really fast it's just really
the awareness I think a lot of times and
I think that's kind of how I feel like
this is going right now with large
language models I think with that public
advancement there are indeed uh serious
safety political economic and other
concerns that do need to be addressed
here as these models get leveraged but I
think there's been a significant
misrepresentation of you know what these
models can really do and how long it has
really taken to get to this point and
how much we can really rely on these
models to do the things that people say
these models can do because while these
models can't do those things
um
it's almost always but not always
so in that way it really
um it just kind of like bums me out that
Microsoft used the phrase AGI in the
title of their paper
in my opinion that's a misrepresentation
um it's poor marketing it's just poor
poor strategy across the board I don't
think that was wise I also can't help
but feel that the comparison of GPT 3.5
and GPT 4
um was misrepresented right almost
everything shown in that GPT for like
Sparks of AGI paper can be done by chat
GPT and to almost the same extent and I
don't like that I don't like that it was
it's represented that that's not true
because I don't even know why we're
trying to diminish GPD 3.5 GPD 3.5 is
also open AI technology it's also a
recent advancement it was the rlhf and
now it appears that rbrm is also being
applied to 3.5 so
I don't know I don't know why do that
other than to over hype oh my gosh we're
advancing so fast you know I I don't
like that I just don't like it and I
also am not a fan of how like there's no
way people at openai who worked on these
models were not seeing all of this hype
and like misrepresentation of what their
model can really do and could be relied
upon to do and seen all of these like
statements about uh you know AGI for
example
um how come nobody spoke up it was like
stop like that's not what this is you
know uh I just
I don't know man I'm a little skeptical
about uh why people were not voicing
their opinions I mean obviously probably
the people open air are just too too
busy to be reading Twitter but some of
them are more public than others and I
just you know I don't know I think the
best way to sort of phrase or put what I
mean by all this is if you only look at
examples where gbd4 or gbd 3.5 gets it
right it can indeed start to look like
gpt4 is indeed AGI and meets the
definition of AGI Microsoft justifies
their use of the phrase AGI in their
paper by going with the definition of
AGI reached by consensus in 1994 which
states AGI is a very general mental
capability that among other things
involves the ability to reason plan
solve problems think abstractly
comprehend complex ideas learn quickly
and learn from experience and I think
all of those things are probably of they
all must come together
uh through many examples we can show
gpt4 has a general mental capability
that can exemplify reason some planning
problem solving abstract thinking
comprehension of complex ideas
I can even imagine some prompt sequences
that might even show learning quickly
and learning from experience a few shot
learning is not a new thing to large
language models for example so yes
through examples we could show all of
those things to be true and as such we
have people shouting and claiming AGI is
here the problem with this is I can also
come up with prompts that exemplify
improve that gpt4 is incapable of all of
those things too so cherry picking
examples goes both ways gbd4 is
certainly impressive as is chat GPT or
gbt 3.5 as are many other large language
models right now and in the wild but I
think it's best to still think of them
as tools treat them as tools learn how
to use them and employ them in your
profession or even for fun but I think
we'd all be like way better off not over
hyping these models or acting like
adding a while loop to them will make
them AGI purely because someone on
Twitter has said so
as for me I'm personally going to be
diving deeper into open Assistant next
As for you if you'd like to learn more
about neural networks and how they work
truly from scratch and stop thinking of
them in this black box form then check
out the neural networks from scratchbook
at
nnfs.io I'll put a link in the
description to those as well otherwise I
hope you all have enjoyed uh peels
please feel free to comment below if you
agreed disagreed or have any further
questions or think I've missed something
or should have covered something all
that I did my best to not editorialize
too much until the very end of I just
tried to to go through the examples uh
and again I I hope this was really more
of a general overview of what large
language models are capable of today
rather than any specific one but gpd4
definitely is uh the kind of bleeding
edge the state of the art so to speak
today
anyways I will see you all in the next
video